comme vous l'avez dit j'interviens avec
plusieurs casquettes devant vous
président de la sous-comission sécurité
et défense qui étudie l'ensemble des
menaces au sein de l'Union européenne et
la manière d'y répondre
des sujets qui sont souvent directement
militaires et c'est naturellement le cas
avec la guerre d'invasion russe en
Ukraine ou les missions militaires de
l'Union européenne à l'étranger mais
aussi les menaces hybrides et puisque
j'ai parlé de l'Ukraine l'Ukraine est un
bon exemple d'un pays qui a d'abord été
ciblé par des menaces hybrides qui fait
face aujourd'hui à une guerre
conventionnelle de haute intensité je
suis aussi coordinatrice de mon groupe
politique
au sein de la Commission spéciale sur
les ingérences qui est présidé par
Raphaël Glucksmann à ce titre je suis
actuellement Cora porteur du rapport
final de la commission spéciale qui se
penche plus particulièrement sur les
menaces d'ingérence contre le Parlement
européen lui-même vous avez tous entendu
parler du catargate mais
d'autres ingérences en particulier en
provenance de Russie et de Chine sont
sur notre radar depuis longtemps nous
les avons à la fois exposés et nous
formulons des recommandations pour nous
en protéger
ces deux casquettes que je viens de
décrire vont bien ensemble et d'ailleurs
les deux commissions celle de que
Raphaël Glucksman président et la mienne
travaille main dans la main au quotidien
j'ai d'ailleurs écrit un livre sur ces
menaces hybrides pour essayer de les
décrire et de faire des propositions et
comme vous l'avez dit je suis également
membre de la délégation aux relations
avec la Chine dans le Parlement européen
je dirais pour commencer que
il est important de mesurer le rôle des
plateformes en général comme outil
d'ingérence de puissance étrangère
toutes les plateformes et différentes
puissances étrangères on l'a vu en 2016
avec l'élection présidentielle
américaine à ce moment la plateforme qui
a été la plus utilisée pour ses
ingérences
a été Facebook
on l'a vu massivement avec la pandémie
de covid et depuis le début de la guerre
du crâne ce sont toutes les plateformes
qui sont le relais de l'opérations de
manipulation de l'information on risque
le voir encore davantage l'année
prochaine 2024 est une année d'élection
dans beaucoup de pays elle commence en
janvier par Taïwan qui a le privilège
c'est j'ose dire d'ouvrir le bal
mais nous aurons également des élections
Royaume-Uni en Ukraine en Russie les
élections européennes et pour terminer
l'élection présidentielle américaine et
nous avons vu j'ai parlé de l'élection
présidentielle américaine de 2016 on
peut parler du référendum sur le brexit
que ces consultations électorales sont
fragiles vulnérables à des ingérences
étrangères
s'agissant des ingérences chinoises je
dirais qu'elle s’est lancée dans les
ingérences avec enthousiasme et avec le
poids que lui confère sa puissance
économique en apprenant des méthodes
russes et en apprenant vite
tout d'abord peut-être un rappel
l'ingérence et la manipulation
d'information font partie de la doctrine
militaire chinoise elle-même qui
distingue l'existence de trois types de
guerre qui peuvent être menées par des
moyens non militaires la guerre de
l'opinion publique la guerre
psychologique et ce qu'on appelle le
l'offer
je me référerai aussi un article de
China de liquidate de décembre 2020 donc
qui est récent et on sait que China
Delhi n'écrit que ce qui est autorisé et
il écrit les médias numériques chinois
et russes devraient combattre ensemble
les attaques et les provocations des
pays occidentaux et mettre en place un
environnement international sain je cite
s'agissant de l'opinion publique nous
voilà donc prévenus
les ingérences de la Chine sont
maintenant bien établis elles passent
par diverses méthodes qu'il s'agisse de
la capture d'élite de l'intrusion via
des coopérations universitaires et
scientifiques du contrôle des diaspora
chinoises à l'étranger des cyberattaques
du financement de des activités de
certains signes temps j'y reviendrai
naturellement si vous avez des questions
mais le monde de l'Internet est un
terrain de jeu des ingérences chinoises
là aussi le paradoxe c'est que Pékin
exerce un contrôle social total sur
l'Internet en Chine ou les plateformes
occidentales sont bannies et où les
plateformes chinoises sont ultra
surveillées mais à l'étranger si j'ose
dire il s'agit d'une activité débridée
pendant le covid la désinformation sur
l'origine du virus ou sur les cités des
vaccins a souvent été made in China avec
des moyens considérables ce qu'on
appelle par exemple l'armée des 50
centimes c'est-à-dire au moins 2
millions de personnes qui en Chine sont
rémunérés pour
intervenir sur les réseaux sociaux
ces 2 millions de personnes on peut y
ajouter 20 millions de ce que
j'appellerai des trolls à temps partiel
imaginaire nommé Wilson Edwards qui
aurait là aussi eu des révélations à
faire sur le covid la Suisse a eu beau
protesté que cette ce biologiste
n'existait pas ces propos ont été repris
par des comptes officiels chinois depuis
le début de la guerre du crâne la
désinformation d'origine chinoise ne
sait pas démenti elle reprend
systématiquement le narratif de la
Russie ce n'est pas une surprise compte
tenu du partenariat sans limite que chez
timping et Vladimir Poutine ont conclu
ensemble alors sur Tik Tok qu'est-ce
qu'on peut en dire que c'est un
instrument qui permet toutes sortes de
manipulations c'est le cas d'autres
plateformes mais il y a quelques
spécificités chinoises qui doivent nous
alerter tout d'abord le format même des
vidéos courtes de Tik Tok qui permet
d'engranger très vite énormément de
données sur les utilisateurs de la
plateforme des données personnelles
qui sont rapatriés en Chine et on sait
que des employés de Tik Tok y ont accès
puisque même Tik Tok a dû le reconnaître
notamment les données de journalistes
qui ont été précisément sur TikTok ont
été aspirés c'est donc possible et c'est
même obligatoire puisqu'on connaît la
loi de 2017 sur la civiversité en Chine
au-delà c'est un outil d'influence qui
émane d'un État autoritaire qui ne nous
laisse donc voir que ce qui est validé
et pas ce qui ne l'est pas c'est un
outil de propagande d'une part et de
censure d'autre part propagande massive
avec des influenceurs qui répètent les
mêmes éléments de langage sur la
plateforme et en revanche des contenus
interdits lorsqu'il risquerait de
déplaire aux autorités de Pékin en
particulier sur ce qui relève des droits
de l'homme en Chine on sait aussi la
présence de cellules du Parti communiste
dans toutes les entreprises chinoises y
compris dans by dance là la maison mère
de Tik Tok et on se souvient des
aventure de Jack ma à la tête d'Alibaba
qui prouve que le patron d'une
entreprise dite privée mais de la tech
en Chine et soumis à de fortes pressions
politiques
c'est la raison pour laquelle dans
l'Union européenne nous nous sommes
dotés de réglementation qui elle couvre
toutes les plateformes et pas seulement
des plateformes chinoises sont des
vision transversale j'y reviendrai là
aussi si vous le souhaitez
essentiellement le rgpd et le DSA pour
répondre aux questions que vous m'avez
posées madame la Présidente est-ce que
nous avons fait l'objet de pression au
sein de la délégation pour les relations
avec la Chine depuis les décisions
prises dans l'Union européenne et
notamment au Parlement d'interdire Tik
Tok sur les outils professionnels des
personnels du Parlement européen je
dirais que la Chine se fait peu
d'illusions sur notre délégation au
point que son président
fait partie des personnes sanctionnées
par la Chine de même que Raphaël
Glucksmann que la sous-commission des
droits de l'homme je crains d'être l'une
des rares personnes qui m'expriment pour
dénoncer le régime chinois à ne pas être
sanctionné non pas que je le réclame et
c'est presque récent c'est presque
exemple
peut-être là c'est parce que ou
peut-être parce que j'étais membre du
gouvernement d'Emmanuel Macron et que le
couper s'est arrêté juste avant moi je
ne sais pas je ne fais pas
d'interprétation des pensées profondes
du régime de Pékin donc nous avons peu
de dialogues avec l'ambassade de Chine
en revanche ce que je relève et là aussi
j'y reviendrai plus en détail si vous le
souhaitez c'est la montée en puissance
du lobbying de Tik Tok aux États-Unis
bien sûr on l'a vu au moment de
l'audition du patron de de
Biden's au Congrès américain à Bruxelles
en parallèle mon groupe politique a
d'ailleurs demandé au patron de Tik Tok
de venir être auditionné au Parlement
europ nous n'avons pas de réponse pour
le moment sur les dangers de sécurité de
Tik Tok je crois les avoir rapidement
évoqués le fait que rien ne permet de
s'assurer aujourd'hui que les données
personnelles des utilisateurs et
notamment d'utilisateurs qui seraient je
dirais des au potentiels politiques ou
des décideurs sont protégés par la
plateforme
la plateforme nous assure que jamais
elle n'a rien transmis aux autorités
chinoises des autorités chinoises
promettent que jamais elles n'ont rien
demandé mais les promesses n'engagent
que ceux qui les écoutent et
l'autorité de contrôle
irlandaise a déclenché deux enquêtes sur
des violations possibles du rgpd par Tik
Tok donc première préoccupation deuxième
préoccupation je l'ai dit outil
d'influence de des informations je
relèverai simplement que le groupe
Wagner est présent sur Tik Tok
et n'est pas sanctionné
que par ailleurs tout ce qui risque de
déplaire à la Chine en est absent cela
suffit à le voir comme une arme
d'influence de la Chine à son profit
dans nos démocraties
merci madame la Présidente et merci à
l'ensemble de la commission pour
l'invitation
quelques mots d'abord sur la Commission
spéciale sur les ingérences étrangères
et dès le début de notre mandature j'ai
demandé la création d'une telle
commission parce qu'il me semblait que
nous faisions preuve d'une naïveté
confondante à l'égard de régime en
particulier de régime autoritaire qui
s'ingérait dans nos élections dans notre
débat public dans notre vie publique et
qui n'était jamais ni sanctionné ni même
confronté et qu'il fallait si nous
voulions être sérieux dans la défense de
notre souveraineté et de notre sécurité
et de nos démocraties et bien d'abord
établir un diagnostic général savoir qui
nous attaque comment quels sont les
failles de nos systèmes de défense et
sur la base de ce diagnostic général et
bien
émettre des recommandations pour mieux
protéger nos démocraties
et mieux faire face à ces attaques cette
commission elle a été finalement créée
en septembre 2020 et depuis nous
travaillons d'ailleurs main dans la main
avec Nathalie Loiseau et avec la plupart
des groupes politiques du Parlement nous
avons un fonctionnement très
transpartisan dans cette commission
parce que il en va de la défense de
notre bien commun qui est la démocratie
et qui est le cadre si vous voulez de
l'expression de nos dissensus sur le
reste mais ce cadre là il est menacé et
on a pu et finalement comprendre que
c'est ingérences elles
elles utilisent différentes méthodes et
je vais entrer dans le détail ensuite
mais des différentes méthodes c'est la
capture des élites et notamment des
élites politiques mais pas seulement
notamment le fait que la Chine et la
Russie soit devenue au fil des années
les pourvoyeurs de retraite dorée de nos
élus de nos gouvernants ou de nos
responsables d'institutions
vous connaissez tous le cas de Garges
Schroeder évidemment pour Gazprom il
faut comprendre que que ça ça a une
influence énorme parce que garage
Schroeder ensuite à piloté finalement le
revirement de la politique énergétique
allemande donc européenne tout cela au
service de gaz Prom et qui n'était pas
le seul et qui a même un terme qui a été
inventé en Russie qui s'appelle
la classe politique c'est à dire la
transformation de la classe politique
européenne en supermarché et
les Chinois évidemment ce sont largement
inspirés des pratiques russes sur cette
question la capture des élites donc
la manipulation de l'information pour
influencer notre débat public sur les
réseaux sociaux notamment mais pas
uniquement
le les investissements dans nos secteurs
stratégiques le financement de mouvement
politique ou d'ONG de think tank qui
repose sur l'absence de transparence
dans beaucoup de d'États membres
bref tout un panoplie d'outils qui sont
utilisés pour deux finalités et là on
distingue les différents types
d'ingérence il y a ce que j'appellerais
les ingérences dites classiques c'est à
dire qu'un État étranger décide
d'utilité d'utiliser des outils
d'influence pour faire en sorte que soit
on prenne des décisions qui lui sont
favorables soit on s'abstienne d'émettre
des critiques et soit on signe des
accords qui
jugent extrêmement bénéfique ça c'est
finalement une ingérence classique qui a
toujours existé et c'est notamment le
cas du Maroc et du Qatar sur la question
du Qatar gate ou du Maroc Gates
c'est-à-dire on va utiliser la
corruption pour obtenir une décision
favorable ou une absence de critique à
l'égard du Qatar ou du Maroc
[Musique]
les deux pôles les plus opposés du débat
public en Espagne à la fois black life
matters et
Olive matters à la fois les gens qui
dénoncent les violences policières en
France et les gens qui demandent qu'on
tire dans la foule les deux en même
temps donc il y a pas de principe de
contradiction là le but est la
déstabilisation et la radicalisation
permanente du débat public dans les
démocraties occidentales pendant
longtemps la Chine parce que c'est
l'objet de la Commission et de et de
l'audition la Chine était plutôt
dans une forme d'ingérence classique
même si massive et il y a eu des moments
de bascule et depuis la pandémie il
semble désormais évident que la Chine a
adopté le modèle russe et d'ailleurs
quand on doute c'est une aparté mais
quand on doute de la solidité de
l'alliance entre Pékin et Moscou il
suffit en fait de voir sur le terrain
sur le terrain de la guerre hybride
quels sont les attitudes des uns et des
autres pour comprendre que cette
alliance pour le moment est absolument
solide c'est à dire que les narratifs
comme Nathalie vient de le dire les
narratifs russes sont totalement repris
poussés par les agents chinois et
finalement il y a une conjonction parce
qu'il y a un objectif commun qui est la
déstabilisation de nos démocraties et
l'affaiblissement des institutions
européennes c'est une évidence quand on
part du terrain de des actions pas quand
on parle nécessairement des discours qui
sont tenus même si les discours vont
dans le même sens
la question des ingériens Chinoises il y
a une spécificité par rapport à la
Russie même c'est que les Russes ont
clairement développé des techniques plus
avancées et ont un objectif chaos encore
plus assumé mais il y a des spécificités
par exemple vous avez posé la question
de du lobbying ou des pressions moi ce
qui me frappe au Parlement européen ou
dans les institution européennes ou dans
le débat public en général quand vous
êtes indécidaire dans les institutions
nationales aussi c'est que le
gouvernement chinois a pas tant besoin
que ça dans d'engager des lobbistes
pourquoi parce que la Chine
contrairement aux autres pays là par
contre peut compter sur le travail des
entreprises européennes et là ça c'est
un vrai problème c'est à dire qu'en fait
on est devenu tellement dépendant du
marché chinois et de l'appareil
productif chinois que nos grands groupes
parce qu'il dépendent de la Chine
devienne si vous voulez des lobbistes
des ambassades bis du gouvernement
chinois et donc quand on doit apprendre
une décision sur le marché intérieur sur
le bannissement des produits de
l'esclavage sur même le l'accord
d'investissement entre l'Union
européenne et la Chine et bien les gens
qui défilent dans nos bureaux sont
beaucoup plus les représentants de
Volkswagen que du gouvernement chinois
lui-même parce que finalement les
intérêts sont conjoints et qui est une
forme de pacte Faustin entre ces grands
groupes et le Parti communiste chinois
ça peut sembler bizarre sur le papier
mais c'est comme ça que ça se fait dans
les couloirs du parlement européen et
donc pour comprendre les ingériens
Chinoises il faut comprendre la
dépendance aussi européenne vis-à-vis de
la Chine et les deux sont intimement
liés pourquoi c'est un problème que par
exemple des ministres d'anciens
ministres français à y travailler pour
Huawei alors que ce serait sans doute
moins un problème s'ils allaient
travailler pour une entreprise
norvégienne ou brésilienne bien parce
que en Russie comme en Chine
le la notion de grande entreprise privée
n'est pas du tout du tout du tout la
même que chez nous et by dance n'est pas
une entreprise privée comme on l'entend
ici bien sûr que c'est une entreprise
privée sur le papier mais en Russie
comment Chine il est impossible pour une
entreprise qui dépasse une taille
critique d'échapper au contrôle du
régime politique
et donc quand vous avez une taille plus
que critique comme by dance et ben vous
êtes soumis non seulement à la loi la
loi de 2017
qui soumet les acteurs tous les acteurs
institutionnels privés y compris
aux exigences de sécurité nationale
émises par le Parti communiste chinois
mais
vous êtes aussi soumis au diktat
politique
plus que légal créé par un écosystème
qui soumet l'ensemble des acteurs privés
aux objectifs affichés par le pouvoir
politique et vous êtes aussi soumis dans
la structure de propriété vous
connaissez tous la pratique des Golden
share du Parti communiste chinois donc
la présence dans les instances décisions
des entreprises privées des
représentants du Parti communiste
chinois et ça pose un problème terrible
parce qu'en fait quand on parle de
naïveté européenne c'est que pendant
très longtemps on a dit mais enfin où
est le problème il s'agit d'entreprise
privée pourquoi ne pas confier la 5G à
Huawei c'était ça le débat en empire
c'est si l'offre est la meilleure
laissons les logiques du marché décidé
c'est le problème c'est que en fait
quand vous avez un acteur qui à
l'intérieur n'applique pas les logiques
du marché appliquez les pures logiques
du marché chez vous c'est mettre en
danger votre sécurité nationale et
laisser la pénétration étrangère et bien
saper les bases de votre souveraineté et
donc si on en vient spécifiquement à la
question de Tik Tok Nathalie Loiseau a
déjà
évoqué les risques mais il y a
un événement quand même enfin les TikTok
leaks qui ont montré à quel point
l'accès
à l'information était non seulement
possible mais réalisé pour les services
chinois parce qu'en fait la question des
serveurs bien sûr que la question de la
location enfin le lieu des serveurs est
extrêmement important mais en réalité
mettre les serveurs en Europe ne
changera rien parce qu'il y aura
toujours un accès l'accès à la question
de l'accès le problème et la question de
l'accès par les autorités chinoises un
gros serveur même s'ils sont placés en
Europe et bien
elle n'est pas résolue cette question là
et nous savons que il y a des donc grâce
à ceelix mais ensuite ça a été reconnu
même qu'il y a des enquêtes qui ont été
menées enfin des intrusions qui ont été
faites et donc il y a la question des
données il y a aussi la question une
question simple pourquoi est-ce qu'une
entreprise qui est une application qui
est aussi perfectionnée techniquement
technologiquement n'a pas de
d'identification multifactor ça c'est
une vraie question que pose tous les
services de sécurité enfin même ceux du
Parlement c'est-à-dire que en fait on a
laissé des des facilités de pénétration
qui n'existent pas nécessairement dans
les autres applications et donc il y a
un risque là de Tik Tok ensuite il y a
le risque que tu as évoqué de la
désinformation sur Tik Tok et là dessus
il y a des études qui ont été faites et
Tik Tok était moins pro par exemple si
on prend les mites termes aux États-Unis
à lutter contre les phénomènes des
informations qui deviennent viraux que
d'autres comme méta ou Youtube même si
encore une fois franchement il y a
aucune plateforme qui est vraiment très
exemplaire là-dessus mais dans le cas de
Tik Tok c'était jugé encore plus faible
donc en fait il y a une conjugaison de
risque
et donc la question qui se pose à nous
c'est que
finalement on doit tirer les leçons de
l'absence de prise en compte des risques
vous savez pendant très longtemps on a
cru que laisser des stocks stratégiques
gaziers allemands sur le territoire
allemand à gaz Rome c'était finalement
c'était un jeu du marché c'était pas
très dangereux la réalité c'est que au
lendemain de l'invasion totale de
l'Ukraine quand monsieur abbek ministre
allemand découvre que les stocks gérés
par Gazprom en Allemagne ont été vidés
pendant les six mois qui précédait la
guerre ce qui veut dire que nous
Européens sommes contraints d'augmenter
nos importations en pleine guerre de
l'énergie de Russie et bien on se rend
compte qu'on a été naïf donc là l'enjeu
c'est de ne plus prendre ce type de
risque
l'enjeu c'est de placer des
considérations de sécurité et de
souveraineté au-dessus des puries de
marché et gardez en tête dans votre
travaux encore une fois la spécificité
des régimes c'est fondamental vous avez
en Chine et en Russie des régimes tout
puissants qui font que les structures
privées leur obéissent et que donc
quelque chose qui est pareil sur le
papier qu'en Europe ne donne pas du tout
les mêmes résultats et ne se traduit pas
du tout de la même manière et voilà
maintenant ça fait disposer à répondre à
vos questions et j'espère que je n'ai
pas été trop long
je vais d'abord donner la parole pour un
porteur Claude malloret pour compléter
par une série de questions j'imagine
merci beaucoup madame la Présidente et
merci à tous les deux d'abord d'avoir
accepté la gravitation et puis de cette
exposé de ces deux exposés préliminaires
tout à fait
pertinent et intéressant je voudrais
vous dire qu'on se réjouit de vous
recevoir aujourd'hui pour différentes
raisons mais je voudrais
particulièrement je pense que ça c'est
inutile pour les bandes de cette
commission mais attirer l'attention je
suppose que tout le monde était au même
niveau d'information que moi sur les
deux ouvrages que vous avez récemment
publiés Nathalie il y a quelques mois et
après lichmann plus récemment et qui me
paraissait d'important et qui sont en
très très en relation et corrélés avec
le ce dont nous
occupons aujourd'hui dans cette
commission
Raphaël
Laurence rossinacité tout à l'heure
Raphaël Glucksmann d'ailleurs il s'est
exprimé là-dessus sur le thème de la
naïveté confondant de l'un de Lens et de
la légèreté des
la démocratie occidentale par rapport
à tous les problèmes posés par les
régimes totalitaires aujourd'hui et les
régimes dictatoriaux c'est évidemment
une des raisons pour lesquelles j'ai
souhaité que cette demander au Sénat de
de se prononcer sur l'établissement de
cette commission je suis heureux qu'il
l'ait fait mais bien entendu
je vous rejoins je voudrais juste citer
une anecdote que Catherine Morin du ci
se rappellera très probablement
en ce qui concerne la naïveté j'ai
proposé en 2018 dans la commission de la
culture aussi où était reçu le ministre
Cédric o de d'interdire en France 2018
je crois que j'ai dit 2018 pardon merci
d'interdire RT et Sputnik
chez Brico à lever les bras au ciel en
disant que nous nous n'étions pas les
dictatures et que c'est un problème de
liberté d'exploitation j'ai eu beau lui
dire que la liberté d'expression
s'appliquait aux médias mais pas
obligatoirement aux officines de
désinformation
issues du directeur ad du MSB mais je
n'ai pas eu je n'ai pas eu gain de cause
et je suis passé pour celui qui luttait
contre la liberté de la 24 février la
naïveté c'est un petit peu 24 février
2022 la naïveté c'est un petit peu
abaissé et et enfin on a supprimé ces
organes de propagande
je voudrais vous poser quelques
questions pas trop parce que je pense
que mes collègues en ont beaucoup
d'autres
la première question
c'est la Commission européenne depuis le
Parlement européen puis un certain
nombre de
gouvernement après les États-Unis et le
Canada mais le gouvernement européen ont
décidé d'interdire à leur fonctionnaires
le téléchargement de l'applique
c'est je dirais c'est à la fois trop et
pas assez parce que ou bien on considère
qu'il y a un danger de Tik Tok et dans
ces conditions en interdit tout
simplement
commerté et consulting pour des raisons
d'espionnage de transfert de données etc
et on recommande au gouvernement
européen de l'interdire purement et
simplement ou bien
il n'y a pas de de raison évidente de
l'interdire aux fonctionnaires si on ne
dit pas pourquoi or et c'est là que
s'ouvre la boîte de Pandore
la Commission européenne n'a pas du tout
expliqué
si ce n'est façon
à l'usive sur les transferts de données
sans doute pour ne pas vexer le
gouvernement chinois en parlant
d'espionnage mais pour le moment la
Commission et les gouvernements
européens ont interdit à leur
fonctionnaires le téléchargement de
l'application
et encore leur fonctionnaires régalien
pour la plupart et pas tous les
fonctionnaires
sans donner de raison alors ma première
question c'est la suivante est-ce que
vous avez ou quelqu'un au Parlement ou
alcovision a posé la question et nous
nous comptons bien la poser si on n'a
pas de réponse d'ici là aux responsable
de la Commission européenne au
commissaire européen
pourquoi a-t-on
interdit le téléchargement de
l'application en fonctionnaire et
pourquoi ne dit-on pas pourquoi
donc ma question c'est est-ce que au
sein de la Commission européenne et du
Parlement cette question a été posée
est-ce que vous avez eu des réponses
est-ce qu'il y a eu des réponses de la
part des responsables de la Commission
européenne ou du Parlement
la deuxième question oui et d'ailleurs
je voudrais rajouter une chose pour la
petite histoire c'est qu'alors que tout
que la Commission le Parlement et tous
les gouvernements européens ont interdit
le téléchargement de l'application Tik
Tok alors fonctionnaire le gouvernement
français qui évidemment n'est pas
n'importe quel gouvernement et qui a
toujours ses spécificités n'est-ce pas y
compris par rapport aux relations avec
nos alliés
je sais pas contenter d'interdire
l'application TikTok sur les smartphones
de leur fonctionnaires mais interdit le
chargement de plusieurs applications
dont Netflix dont je me rappelle plus
lesquels etc donc je voudrais voir votre
sentiment là-dessus parce que est-ce que
vous pensez que cette décision était
justifiée interdiction de télécharger
Netflix sur les smartphones ou est-ce
que vous pensez qu'à quelque chose de la
visite puisque cette décision était
prise il y a une quinzaine de jours qui
a quelques jours de la du président
Macron en Chine c'était destiné à ne pas
cibler plus particulièrement une
application et une plateforme chinoise
ma question suivante
vous avez un peu vous l'avez un peu
abordé
c'est que diktok évidemment nous assure
qu'ils n'ont qu'il n'y a aucun lien avec
la Chine avec le gouvernement chinois
etc et que d'ailleurs le capital
aujourd'hui est réparti et largement
majoritairement non chinois il explique
d'ailleurs que la preuve c'est que
le siège de Gilles caïman moi si j'étais
à leur place je prendrai pas comme
exemple de transparence le fait d'avoir
établi mon siège aussi le caïman parce
que ça va être un petit peu compliqué de
savoir s'ils disent la vérité dans cette
répartition du capital mais quoi qu'il
en soit ils disent il y a pas de lien
avec le en chinois quand et la maison
mère ce que nous appelons la maison mère
mais qu'il n'appelle pas la maison mère
by dance n'est pas majoritaire la
capitale alors c'est un cette
cette déclaration étant étant qui a été
répété d'ailleurs au Congrès lorsque
sous-titchou a été auditionné par les
membres du Congrès américain et
directement contre dite par le
gouvernement chinois
probablement d'ailleurs à son insu ou
sans l'avoir voulu puisque lorsque les
Américains sugèrent de vendre que
l'application Tik Tok soit vendue à des
sociétés américaines pour ne plus avoir
les risques
inhérents à la situation actuelle le
gouvernement chinois dit il n'en est pas
question nous ne vendrons jamais TikTok
nous ne laisserons jamais Tic-Toc vendre
ce qui est la preuve même que c'est bien
le gouvernement chinois qui
[Musique]
qui
mène le jeu si je peux dire donc je
voulais vous demander si vous avez
au-delà des deux facteurs qui sont
évidemment ceux de toutes les grandes
sociétés chinoises d'abord ceux d'avoir
à apprendre à la moindre du service de
renseignement chinois deuxièmement
d'avoir une cellule du PC chinois dans
dans le mais c'est pas le cas de Tik Tok
directement est-ce que vous avez quel
est votre sentiment de façon plus plus
précise sur les rapports
entre la société non pas entre la
société by dance mais entre la société
Tik Tok et même et le gouvernement
chinois est-ce que par un moyen ou pas
un autre ou par des successions de
moyens
il est important pour nous d'établir le
degré moi je suis assez persuadé que est
assez fort mais d'établir de façon la
plus précise possible degré de
d'affiliation de ces sociétés au
gouvernement et aux parties communistes
chinois ce qui n'est pas tout à fait la
même chose mais
je voudrais vous poser une question sur
vous en avez parlé aussi donc sur les
établissement de serveur en Europe le
projet Texas aux États-Unis et le projet
Clover en Europe
je vais pas vous poser une question
technique parce que la question
technique nous nous nous avons
d'ailleurs déjà posé à des
informaticiens à des sociétés
spécialisées il nous paraît d'ailleurs à
la suite de ces auditions assez évident
que le projet Clover d'abord il est
question d'installer les serveurs dans
deux pays européens qui sont très
particuliers le premier c'est l'Irlande
qui pour des raisons fiscales etc ne
joue pas systématiquement le jeu de
l'ensemble des autres pays européens et
le deuxième c'est la Rush qui n'est pas
un pays européen au sens qu'il
n'appartient pas à l'Union européenne ce
qui déjà pose des problèmes sur le choix
de ces deux de ces deux pays il paraît
évident à suivre des auditions que nous
avons eu qu'il n'est pas possible
d'éviter les portes dérobées et que
quand vous le tout à l'heure de toute
façon à partir du moment où les données
doivent être traitées un certain nombre
de données doivent être traitées en
Chine par des ingénieurs chinois on voit
pas comment ils pourraient en être
autrement mais
la
question que je voulais vous poser n'est
pas une question technique c'est une
question politique puisque
à titre politique
quel est aujourd'hui au sein du
Parlement et de la Commission européenne
la sensibilité sur ou
sur le fait d'accepter ou non de
recommander ou non le projet Clover
est-ce que vous pensez que la Commission
européenne est susceptible de d'accepter
ce projet de le recommander il est
d'ailleurs déjà il est d'ailleurs
particulièrement opaque même à ce stade
quel est votre sentiment sur la que sera
la position demain du Parlement européen
et de la Commission européenne sur le
projet Clover
question suivante et celle de
l'interdiction ou de la régulation
depuis qu'on a créé cette commission
ta journaliste qui viennent nous voir et
la première question qui pose c'est
alors est-ce que vous allez interdirect
nous on se reçoit la question comme ça
on se pose d'abord la question de savoir
qu'est-ce que c'est du club qu'est-ce
qu'il y a dans ce dans ce mécanisme
d'essayer de l'ouvrir un peu et ensuite
d'en tirer des conclusions qui peuvent
être de toute nature on n'est pas là on
n'a pas créé cette commission pour dire
on va interdire Tik Tok mais il n'en
reste pas moins que sur ce sujet se pose
d'ores et déjà avant même toute
conclusion de problèmes
le premier problème c'est celui de la
réciprocité est-ce que vous pensez
qu'il est possible
durablement que les plateformes
occidentales soient interdites purement
et simplement en Chine
et contrepartie la Chine fait ce qu'elle
veut je lui dis tout à l'heure sur les
plateformes occidentales et qu'en plus
les
Occidentaux laissent la Chine développer
n'importe quelle plateforme parce que
Tik Tok n'est pas la seule peut-être il
est peut-être à mon avis en tout cas
wechat qui s'occupe qui qui se qui ne
s'adresse pas à nous mais qui s'adresse
à toutes les communautés chinoises dans
le monde entier c'est-à-dire quelque
chose de extrêmement énorme et qui est
peut-être de ce point de la plus
problématique que Tik Tok nous laissons
tous là ce voilà la première question
est-ce qu'à titre de non pas de
comment dire de
de menaces d'espionnage ou autre de
transfert de données mais à titre de
d'équilibre politique et commercial
est-ce qu'il vous paraît normal et
est-ce que d'être dans cette situation
et qu'est-ce que vous recommanderiez de
ce point de la deuxième point par
rapport à l'interdiction ou régulation
si on dit on n'interdit pas Tic-Toc à la
fin de la conclusion et que il faut
probablement
envisager une
ce moment là le problème de la
régulation est-ce que vous pensez
aujourd'hui que le DMA le DSA je crois
que Nathalie on a dit deux mots tout à
l'heure est-ce que vous pensez que le
DMA est le DSA sont des outils
suffisants pour réguler d'ailleurs pas
seulement Tik Tok mais d'autres
plateformes mais nous on s'occupe des
Tik Tok ou est-ce que vous pensez et
est-ce que le Parlement européen et la
Commission sont aujourd'hui en train de
se pencher d'ores et déjà parce que les
choses évoluent évidemment beaucoup plus
rapidement que le législateur à chaque
fois
sont déjà en train de se pencher sur
les nécessités les futures nécessité de
la régulation par rapport à ces
plateformes mais notamment par rapport à
Tik Tok
et enfin je voudrais vous poser une
dernière question
aucune plateforme est exemplaire sur le
plan
des données de l'algorithme disait
Raphaël Glucksmann tout à l'heure
j'avais
le Sénat le Français a voté il y a deux
ans et là aussi mes collègues s'en
souviennent sans doute contre la vie du
gouvernement un amendement à la loi sur
le séparatisme qui disait la chose
suivante c'est un moment que j'avais
proposé dans je ne vais jamais pensé
qu'il serait voté et qu'il a été à
l'unanimité contre la vie du
gouvernement disons toute plateforme
qui
je me rappelle plus les termes
catégorise cette diffusion
d'informations à partir
d'algorithmes ou d'autres
traitements informatiques analogue
entraîne un choix dans le et qui se
prétend hébergeur et qui nous dit et qui
dit je ne suis pas un éditeur
puisque je ne me contente de diffuser
c'est d'ailleurs tout le lobbying des
gafam à Bruxelles qui dépensent des
milliards pour essayer d'éviter quand
les désigne comme producteur et non pas
comme hébergeur donc toute plateforme
qui fait de la curation au sens anglais
du terme c'est à dire qui trie les
informations que ce soit à partir
d'algorithmes à partir d'autres outils
informatiques déterminent par le même
une ligne éditoriale et devient des
facto un éditeur et non pas un hébergeur
et de ce point de vue là et comme le dit
Thierry Breton ce qui doit être ce qui
est interdit offline de s'interdy online
et la modération de doit se faire
préalablement et non pas expost
cette la vie du gouvernement était pour
le par lui-même ministre et pour les
mêmes raisons celui de la liberté
d'expression le contraire mais le Sénat
a voté à l'unanimité évidemment il n'est
jamais passé à l'assemblée que je
voudrais vous demander ce que vous
pensez sur cette diffusion sur cette
distinction entre éditeur et
diffuseur et si vous pensez qu'on peut
longtemps continuer avec des plateformes
pas seulement Tik Tok mais les
plateformes qui continuent sur ce thème
de pouvoir diffuser ce à peu près ce
qu'elles veulent modéré avec une
insuffisance criante et encore plus
vivante chez Tik Tok que chez les autres
ou s'il va falloir quand même et
notamment au niveau européen régler cela
je vous remercie je m'excuse à mon tour
d'avoir été sans doute plus long que je
ne souhaitais
je vais vous donner la parole dans un
instant à prendre à les questions parce
que comme le président maldurait a déjà
bien été fourni dans ces questions à
votre égard moi je voudrais en rajouter
peut-être une à cet instant j'avais les
mêmes questions sur la réciprocité elle
est abordée par le Président madurée je
n'avais une c'est effectivement vous
allez peut-être y répondre c'est comment
comment on identifie la nationalité de
Tik Tok voilà mais je crois que la poser
et enfin une autre c'est quelle est
l'accès des Chinois Tik Tok est-ce que
les chinois ont un accès
voilà comment les Chinois qu'est-ce que
les Chinois voient sur Tik Tok voilà et
enfin sur hébergeur diffuseur je
confirme et j'appuie la question dans la
mesure où pour travailler sur la
diffusion des contenus pornographiques
nous avons exactement le même problème
sur les contenus pornographiques et si
vous avez un mot à nous dire sur Tik Tok
et des contenus pornographiques nous
sommes au moins deux à être preneuse et
probablement tous nos collègues aussi
je vais essayer d'être très très rapide
et
toute façon ce qui est bien c'est que je
peux compter sur Nathalie pour être
exhaustive derrière
aujourd'hui le
les mesures qui sont prises c'est la
vraie question pourquoi et pourquoi il y
a pas de pourquoi
pourquoi elles sont pas expliquées et
ensuite je m'expliquerai sur enfin je
m'exprimerai sur Netflix
[Musique]
alors non on a reçu une note
confidentielle à partager mais je n'ai
pas le droit de le faire publiquement
qui explique les risques
elle a pas été communiquée publiquement
d'ailleurs ça c'est une vraie question
c'est à dire
il n'y a pas de volonté d'expliquer
publiquement pourquoi on cible
spécifiquement Tik Tok
[Musique]
c'est de toute façon une mesure de
précaution c'est à dire que c'est fondé
sur l'idée de risques c'est pas fondé
sur
des preuves
d'espionnage avéré même si on a
ces risques sont conséquents et le fait
de ne pas les partager à mon avis
et problématique politiquement
démocratiquement et relève d'une
politique européenne depuis longtemps
qui est de ne pas
antagoniser la Chine et je pense que
cette politique est
porté à sa quintessence avec la décision
du gouvernement français sur Netflix
parce que tout ce que nous on essaye
d'expliquer dans la commission spéciale
c'est quand même que oui il faut des
critères objectifs et généraux il s'agit
pas de faire comme les américains et de
cibler à chaque fois spécifiquement
la Chine le gouvernement chinois une
région en Chine mais
il s'agit quand même pas non plus de
faire semblant que Netflix et Tik Tok
pose les mêmes problèmes
et je pense que c'est d'ailleurs
une faille dans le raisonnement européen
que l'on retrouve à chaque étape de
notre commission spéciale
je m'expliquer
l'absence de volonté ou la volonté de ne
pas faire de liste par exemple d'entités
problématiques pour notre souveraineté
notre sécurité
conduit à des réflexions parfois
lunaires parce qu'elle s'impose un
caractère universel et indice dans les
cibles
comment faire pour réglementer je vais
prendre un exemple qui n'est pas la
question des plateformes et vous allez
comprendre ce que ça produit en fait
comme type de réflexion comment faire
pour réglementer les travaux que des
sénateurs ou des députés ou des
ministres vont faire après leur mandat
ou leur rôle
on est là dans une réflexion en
particulier après le catargate qui qui
est qui est extrêmement intense et on
parle de cette cooling of période de
cette période de refroidissement ou
chacun devra s'abstenir d'aller
travailler pour telle ou tel intérêt
privé le problème c'est que travailler
pour gasporam et travailler pour une
entreprise norvégienne
de bois c'est pas la même chose
c'est pas la même chose et c'est traité
de la même manière donc là on a on a un
peu un problème c'est à dire que les
services de sécurité ils vont nous
alerter sur Gazprom plus que sur la
question de l'entreprise de bois en
Norvège mais si on traite tout de
manière universelle si on sait pas
spécifiquement quelque chose sur gaz
prendre et bien on va se retrouver très
rapidement dans des discussions qui
peuvent conduire à des aporis parce que
en gros si c'est on interdit à tout
officiel ou à tout serviteur de l'État
d'aller travailler dans une entreprise
privée toute sa vie on va avoir un
problème de recrutement dans les
entreprises dans l'état et voilà il y
aura plus que des fonctionnaires et je
comprends qu'il y aurait quand même que
une forme de d'insurrection morale face
au fait qu'on paye toutes leurs vies des
gens parce qu'ils ont été ministre
pendant un an
ça posera problème et donc en même temps
on peut pas les faire mourir de faim non
plus donc qu'est-ce qui se passe et bien
c'est à dire que il va falloir quand
même qu'on se décide à faire en sorte
que un ministre de la Défense ne puisse
pas aller travailler pour un fond ouais
pour la Chine ou pour la Russie alors
qu'il pourrait tout à fait et travailler
pour la tendresse enfin pour une
entreprise norvégienne ça nous poserait
pas le moindre problème
donc il y a une mesure de précaution et
qui et qui quand elle est étendue à
Netflix tu es un peu de son sens à mon à
mon humble invisible c'est la vie si
vous voulez que je vous réponde
franchement
quand le gouvernement chinois j'allais
vous mais vous avez mis dans la question
la réponse
quand le gouvernement chinois dit nous
ne laisserons pas faire ça veut dire
qu'en fait la structure officielle de
propriété de Tik Tok ne reflètent en
rien le processus de décision
et c'est tout le problème de ces régimes
opaque c'est que vous pouvez très bien
avoir sur le papier une structure de
propriété qui est majoritairement à
l'extérieur de la Chine
il n'empêche que dans le fonctionnement
c'est le gouvernement chinois le Parti
communiste chinois qui va décider des
orientations qui seront prises ou qui ne
seront pas prises
et la même chose ressort des 80 réunions
qui ont été
enregistrées et qui ont donné lieu au
Tik Tok
clicksfit c'est que en fait
la pratique est la vérité ça doit être
ça la base de notre approche la pratique
de Gasprom et la vérité de Gazprom pas
la structure officielle la pratique de
Tik Tok est la vérité Tik Tok donc sur
le papier ça peut très bien devenir une
entreprise européenne basée en Irlande
la question c'est qui commande
concrètement réellement et là-dessus
vous pouvez avoir toutes les garanties
sur le papier il y aura toujours
le la même suspicion parce que on ne
refuse rien aux autorités politiques
chinoises et que les exemples qui sont
faits on va parler de la vie tout à
l'heure font que de personnes ne leur
refusera rien qui a des liens avec la
Chine et qui donc est forcément
dépendant de la bonne volonté du pouvoir
politique sur les serveurs encore une
fois vraiment j'insiste c'est le lieu
des serveurs
et moins important que la question de
l'accès au serveur et de l'accès au data
et là dessus c'est pareil c'est la
pratique qui décide sur et je veux pas
répondre à tout parce que je vais être
trop long l'interdiction la régulation
c'est la grande question
moi je peux le juste vous livrer la mon
point de vue personnel je pense pas
qu'on en soit aujourd'hui au moment où
on va bannir TikTok de l'ensemble du
continent européen ça sera pas ça qui
sera décidé par contre
il y a des questions de régulation et il
y a des questions de réciprocité vous
les avez mentionnés et le fait est que
on risque d'arriver à ce bannissement
parce que il y a une un déséquilibre
total
dans nos relations avec la Chine c'est
vrai du commerce et c'est vrai de
l'information c'est d'ailleurs on se met
dans une position
c'est la même chose avec la Russie ou en
gros il y a un contrôle absolu de toute
influence qui pourrait émaner de nos
démocraties en Chine et que nous on n'a
pas du tout la même attitude c'est tout
à notre honneur mais ça doit pas devenir
finalement une naïveté sur les
algorithmes et là je voudrais juste être
un tout petit peu plus long là dessus
sur les algorithmes sur votre amendement
je pense que c'est fondamental
et là dessus je veux juste expliquer
pourquoi et ça concerne pas que Tik Tok
là par contre
les les
algorithmes des plateformes
qui sont les secrets les mieux gardés de
ces plateformes
finalement
cherche quoi à maximiser votre présence
sur la plateforme à vous attirer à vous
exciter à vous rendre dépendant et donc
on l'a vu par exemple ce qui a été
révélé des émoticônes sur facebook quand
la colère et cinq fois plus mise en
avant que l'approbation parce que la
colère est plus addictive et bien c'est
ces algorithmes qui dictent qui sont les
lois en fait de notre nouvelle Agora et
ça c'est tout le paradoxe c'est qu'en
fait notre notre débat public a
désormais lieu dans un espace privé
il faut essayer de comprendre ce que ça
suppose voilà c'est l'opposé de la place
publique donc en fait on est notre place
publique est devenu un espace privé
notre Agora est un lieu privé régi par
des lois que le décideur public
que le législateur ne connaît pas
et c'est lois c'est ça l'enjeu des
algorithmes et c'est lois et bien
favorise les branlements de notre
démocratie
parce que c'est lois favorisent les
opinions les plus polarisantes et les
addicts addicts
drogués au point de vue de la colère et
donc là on a une recette pour une
catastrophe et
le régime russe ce qui on a plus accès
alors réflexion théorique là-dessus le
régime russe la parfaitement compris
c'est-à-dire que le chef d'orchestre de
la propagande poutinienne depuis le
début du règne de Poutine qui s'appelle
sorcov et peut-être lu le match du
Kremlin
une théorise le chaos il théorise
l'expansion du chaos et cette fois-ci
pas dans une fiction mais dans un
véritable article de 2021 sur coffre à
ce moment là il est responsable de la
politique ukrainienne de Poutine quand
même sur coffre
il explique que la seule manière pour la
Russie le régime russe de continuer à
exister c'est l'expansion du chaos pour
remédier phénomène récurrent des
tensions intérieures et donc le but
c'est l'expansion du chaos le but de
cette propagande n'est pas d'être cru
mais elle est débranlée notre rapport à
la vérité de fait qu'on ne croit plus en
rien et qu'on soit en énervement
permanent et bien cette approche là
correspond magnifiquement aux
algorithmes des plateformes et donc en
fait on joue nous tout le temps sur un
terrain extérieur maintenant c'est comme
si on était une équipe de foot qui
passait son temps à jouer à l'extérieur
alors même que on bloquait tout l'accès
à ces plateformes et donc il joue à la
maison chez nous c'est aussi basique que
ça grâce à ses algorithmes puisque leur
approche correspond au terrain de jeu et
aux règles et aux lois du terrain de jeu
et donc là
je veux dire je veux bien qu'ils aiment
beaucoup l'argent et que leur but soit
de s'étendre indéfiniment mais il y a
une contrepartie à cela je parle du
plateformes il y a une contrepartie à
cela c'est c'est la responsabilité parce
que il y a un moment où le pouvoir
public
et bien ne peut pas autoriser des
acteurs privés à sapés comme ça des
fondements sur lesquels ils reposent et
c'est pour ça qu'il faut impérativement
que la responsabilité soit imposée
là-dessus d'ailleurs je dois dire
l'Union européenne par rapport aux
États-Unis et précurseur c'est à dire
que on a des Etats-Unis qui toc très
bien mais par contre quand il s'agit de
réguler de manière générale les
plateformes et bien c'est l'Union
européenne qui en avance là-dessus donc
je suis souvent critique sur les
positions de l'Union européenne et sur
les retards pris à l'allumage des
institutions européennes mais il se
trouve que là dessus on est en avance
nous par exemple quand on a échangé avec
les autorités australiennes
enquêtes elles analysent ce que nous
faisons en ce moment et l'idée c'est
quand même de bâtir une coalition sans
les États-Unis sur cette question là
pour obliger les Américains à réfléchir
réellement à l'influence alors même que
quand même ils ont eu des images que
vous avez toutes et tous vu du Capitole
et que c'est une conséquence notamment
des algorithmes des des plateformes donc
il y a là un enjeu fondamental et
c'est pour ça que votre amendement était
fondamental
merci je vais pas reprendre ce qu'a dire
Raphaël bustman que je partage un
premier mot sur
à ton dit pourquoi on suspendait où on
interdisait l'installation de de Tik Tok
sur les outils des fonctionnaires
européens il faut voir que l'Union
européenne c'est à la fois un grand
marché et aussi une construction
juridique donc elle est toujours
extrêmement pointilleuse dans ce qu'elle
dit publiquement elle n'est pas toujours
très politique c'est loin qu'on puisse
dire elle le devient mais elle le
devient face aux crises et un peu dans
la douleur
celui qui est allé le plus loin dans
l'explication c'est l'organisme de
régulation belge qui a pris la même
décision que d'autres et qui a dit des
choses assez claires en disant Tik Tok
collecte une grande quantité de données
auprès des utilisateurs et peut
manipuler les flux d'information et de
contenu la loi ch Tik Tok à coopérer
avec les services de renseignement
chinois raison pour laquelle on demande
au fonctionnaires belges de ne plus
charger TikTok je vous ai offert
gratuitement la traduction d'un
communiqué qui est en néerlandais et eux
ils sont allés bah c'est frontalement là
où les autres ont été plus vagues plus
généraux alors est-ce que c'est un
défaut de mélanger Tik Tok avec d'autres
paradoxalement je ne suis pas sûr je ne
suis pas sûr parce que ce qu'on reproche
à la Chine de faire au travers de son
outil à elle et Raphaël Luxman a raison
de dire c'est la pratique qui compte
Tik Tok est un outil de propagande et
d'influence de la Chine mais elle le
fait aussi à travers les autres
plateformes
elle le fait à travers twitter facebook
j'ai quelque part les chiffres pendant
la pandémie de covid de la manière dont
Twitter a essayé de courir après la
désinformation puisque c'était le
premier sujet sur lesquels les
plateformes admettaient que quand il y
avait une question de vie ou de mort
elles avaient une responsabilité et on y
reviendra sur le fait que à partir de là
ils ont admis qu'elle n'était pas
simplement des tuyaux mais qu'elles
avaient une responsabilité 2019
Twitter bloque
environ environ 500 faux comptes chinois
2020 je crois que c'est 130 000 et
quelques chiffres précis quelque part
donc l'influence la manipulation de
l'information elle passe à travers
toutes les plateformes
TikTok en études mais c'est loin d'être
la seule et je considère que l'approche
européenne qui considère qui souhaite
réguler toutes les plateformes c'est pas
une approche l'âge qui ne veut pas voir
où est la difficulté c'est une approche
de précaution vis-à-vis de tous
et pour répondre à votre question sur
Clover d'abord la présentation qui en a
été faite et pour le moment extrêmement
flou on sait peu de choses on sait que
TikTok s'engage à avoir des centres de
données donc en Irlande et en Norvège
alors en Irlande on sait que c'est pour
des raisons fiscales il y a à peu près
pas de pas de doute là-dessus dire que
l'Irlande ferme davantage les yeux que
d'autres c'est de moins en moins vrai
l'Autorité de régulation irlandaise
peut-être piquer au vif et aussi parce
qu'elle est armée aujourd'hui du rgpd et
du DSA fait son travail c'est elle qui a
déclenché deux procédures d'enquête sur
l'utilisation des données par TiK ToK on
va voir ce qu'elles deviennent mais en
tout cas elle a l'obligation de le faire
aujourd'hui
en revanche quand Tik Tok nous dit
qu'ils vont avoir un audit indépendant
d'une entreprise de cybersécurité quel
audit sur quel critère quelle entreprise
on connaissais rien et c'est
probablement pas suffisant pour être
rassuré
sur l'approche qui est celle de la
régulation donc celle qui a été prise
d'abord par le rgpd ensuite par le DSA
ça n'est pas l'alpha et l'oméga c'est
pas les tables de la Loi gravées dans le
marbre mais c'est un premier pas
important intéressant justement parce
que s'agissant du DSA on est plus dans
la naïveté de dire les plateformes sont
des tuyaux elles n'ont pas de
responsabilité on les met devant le
responsabilité la Commission les
autorités de régulation des États
membres doivent avoir accès au Graal
c'est-à-dire aux algorithmes de
recommandations
les plateformes elles-mêmes ont des
responsabilités et là on n'est pas allé
assez loin c'est à elle en quelque sorte
de faire en sorte d'atténuer les risques
de contenu
préjudiciables quel qu'il soit
évidemment vraiment du thé contre les
contenus illégaux on a d'ailleurs ajouté
d'autres réglementations par exemple sur
les contenus terroristes pour leur
donner des obligations spécifiques on
travaille sur les contenus pédaux
pornographiques il y a eu une première
réglementation qui était j'allais dire
intérimaire pour éviter qu'on se
retrouve sans aucune réglementation et
maintenant on travaille sur une
réglementation plus durable c'est à nous
de donner des orientations sur ce qui
est illégal hors ligne qui doit devenir
complètement en ligne est-ce qu'on va
assez loin la vraie question le vrai
test maintenant pour les très grandes
plateformes pour lequel le DSA est déjà
en vigueur depuis quelques semaines
c'est notre capacité à faire respecter
cette réglementation c'est à dire à
enquêter à considérer qu'il y a eu une
brèche dans la réglementation et à
imposer les sanctions en sanctions qui
peuvent être très significatives puisque
elles sont de plusieurs pourcentages du
chiffre d'affaires mondial de ces
plateformes donc elles sont
véritablement
dissuasives à mal se comporter et là on
entre dans le moment de test est-ce que
la commission dont c'est pas l'ADN
immédiat
je vais être capable de taper du point
sur la table de dire là nous vous avons
vu vous avez été en violation du DSA je
dirais que le premier des tests il est
sur Twitter de Elon Musk aujourd'hui
quand on voit ce que c'est que
l'effondrement de la modération de
Twitter quand on voit ce que sont
aujourd'hui les algorithmes de
recommandation de Twitter qui font que
vous avez sur votre fil des choses que
vous n'avez jamais sollicité il y a
évidemment une question à se poser
au-delà de la question à se poser il y a
un dialogue très ferme à avoir avec
Twitter et il y a à faire respecter par
Twitter comme Elon Musk avait un peu
rapidement promis le DJ Stone c'est un
vrai sujet c'est un vrai instrument qui
est sans doute pas le dernier parce que
la technologie va vite mais je pense
vraiment que
au-delà de la spécificité de Tik Tok les
ingérences étrangères notamment
chinoises passent par toutes les
plateformes et que si
on banni TikTok d'une certaine manière
ça renaîtra autrement et de toute façon
ça prendra d'autres canaux sur le
château des Spoutnik je partage tout à
fait ce que disait le président malgré
pour autant si on regarde les chiffres
de la désinformation d'origine russe
qui circule par des moyens numériques en
Europe depuis le l'interdiction de le
château des et de Spoutnik on a donné un
coup de pied dans la fourmilière et ça
s'est répandu par tout ailleurs c'est
extraordinairement compliqué de se dire
que la mesure comprend aussi
spectaculaire soit-elle est suffisante
par rapport au but qu'on
poursuit en revanche la notion de
réciprocité que on brandit toujours
quand on parle de la Chine et qu'on
applique peu parce que les Chinois
bannissent simplement de réciprocités
dans nos échanges devrait être au cœur
de nos échanges avec la Chine
c'est-à-dire que accepter une plateforme
comme Tik Tok et accepter que les
plateformes occidentales elles ne sont
pas représentées en Chine est un vrai
sujet c'est d'abord un sujet pour les
États-Unis puisque pas de plateforme
européenne
et on voit bien la réponse américaine
qui est de dire on va peut-être bannir
Tik Tok tout simplement parce qu'il y a
pas de régulation américaine et qui a
une concurrence
économique commerciale entre les
plateformes américaines et la sorte
chinoise qu'on regarde passer au dessus
de nos têtes on n'est pas exactement
dans la même position que les États-Unis
et les États-Unis se sont mis dans une
position où leur la légitimité de leur
préoccupations est un peu terni par leur
souci de gains ou de d'absence de perte
commerciale
on l'a dit aucune plateforme n'est
exemplaire c'est bien pour ça que Tik
Tok comme les autres doit passer par le
DSA
quel est l'accès des Chinois à Tik Tok
non il y a un Tik Tok spécial Chine
qui est encore plus contrôlé encore plus
verrouillé que que le véritable Tik Tok
mais TikTok sert évidemment à des
publics occidentaux surtout jeunes c'est
d'ailleurs une des raisons qui a fait
que dans le digital service Act il y a
des mesures particulières de protection
des mineurs qui sont demandés aux
plateformes notamment au très grandes
plateformes à la fois protection des
données protection sur les contenus
quand vous êtes une très grande
plateforme qui que vous soyez vis-à-vis
des mineurs vous avez plus de
responsabilité
[Musique]
sur les contenus pornographiques je l'ai
dit l'Europe travaille d'abord et avant
tout sur le contenu pedo pornographique
pour leur faire la chasse toutes les
plateformes quelle que soit leur
nationalité vont vous dire que c'est
très compliqué que ces techniquesment
infables c'est tout à fait faisable
techniquement simplement ça coûte de
l'argent et nous nous leur disons à
l'inverse que ne pas le faire ça leur
coûte en réputation et de ce point de
vue là ça fonctionne assez bien et je
dirais que sur les contenus pédops
pornographiques un certain nombre de
plateformes ont mis au point des outils
qu'il faut évidemment contrôler pour
être sûr qu'ils ne sont pas intrusifs
sur notre vie privée mais on a un vrai
débat au Parlement européen et parfois
certains citrons étant tellement
préoccupés par la préoccupée par la
protection de la vie privée qui serait
prêt à protéger les pédocrinels
et d'ailleurs ils le font et les
plateformes de ce point de vue là sont
plutôt du côté de ceux qui veulent
lutter contre la pédophile parce qu'ils
ont bien compris le risque réputationnel
auquel ils sont exposés c'est là où on
voit toute l'ambiguïté du dialogue qu'on
peut avoir avec quelle est la richesse
réelle de TikTok ou de la de sa marque
mais la valorisation de sa marque ça
veut pas dire grand chose si c'est pas
les recettes publicitaires ce sont ces
données les données massives qu'elle
obtient sur les personnes des données ça
se valorise soit d'un point de vue
publicitaire compris en termes de
publicité ciblées ce que ne fait pas
TikTok en tous les cas dans la partie
occidentale ça se valorise pour
développer un algorithme alors ça oui il
l'utilise puis des données
logiquement ça peut se revendre ce
qu'ils ne font pas donc quand je regarde
la stratégie du gouvernement chinois et
ça nous a été confirmé par les services
nous sommes tous les jours dans les pays
européens américains payés sur des bases
de données personnelles de nos services
publics avec des moyens d'infraction
comment le gouvernement chinois se
priverait des données concernant plus
d'un milliard d'utilisateurs très
précises dans le reste du monde c'est à
dire que la question du transfert des
données
les galles ou pas légal doit bien existé
puisque c'est une source d'information
la deuxième chose qu'est-ce qu'on fait
c'est donner une fois qu'elles sont
prises le temps de conservation des
données on se rend compte qu'aujourd'hui
quand l'Italie a décidé en tout cas le
régulateur italien a décidé de suspendre
provisoirement tchat gypetti c'était
précisément sur la question du respect
ou pas du règlement personnel et aussi
des âges de consentement et chaque Zippy
a dit nous allons relancer la production
avec beaucoup moins de données
personnelles et avec moins d'historique
sur les personnes l'usage de
l'intelligence artificielle notamment
sur la base des données pose cette
question de combien de coton garde-t-on
des données c'est pas simplement où les
stockons ou les analystesons et
là-dessus on n'a pas d'éléments alors
est-ce que
l'approche économique vous paraît une
approche fiable parce que si on veut
comprendre ce qui est TikTok et à quoi
ça sert ou éventuellement à qui ça peut
servir mais c'est très compliqué pour
les rares données dont nous disposons
notamment les fameuses années Forbes sur
la présence d'employés de les tâches
chinois dans baytens et TiK ToK on les a
obtenus sur la base des travaux des
employés qui sont inscrits sur Linkedin
c'est le seul base dont on dispose donc
il y a un problème de transparence et
jusqu'à quel moment on peut accepter
qu'une entreprise ne publie pas des
comptes ne publie pas des résultats
réels les bases de ces dépenses et ses
coûts ça c'est un vrai problème surtout
quand on est que le capital est
largement extérieur donc est-ce que
cette problématique vous vous paraît
parce qu'on nous dit souvent pour lutter
contre la mafia il faut la prendre au
porte-monnaies alors je n'accuse pas
TikTok ou by dance d'être la mafia mais
enfin il y a quand même une absence de
transparence qui dépasse très largement
la faible transparence qui est sur les
grandes plateformes ou les grands
groupes numériques internationaux
dernière dans mes collègues ont demandé
à poser une question Rémi Cardon après
je vous laisserai répondre et conclure
et nous serons arrivés une heure
raisonnable pour lever cette séance
merci madame la Présidente effectivement
une question avec une mise en contexte
ça a été dit
on doit aussi tout se poser la question
de pas que se focaliser sur Tik Tok
parce que en fait si on en regarde
l'ancienneté les plateformes américaines
se sont installées et le business model
que tu viens de définir chers collègues
en réalité c'est la recherche de
volumétrie en termes d'utilisateur pour
s'installer dans une société et après
jouer sur des campagnes d'influence
c'est ça le modèle le business model et
puis par la suite on a vu les évolutions
de Facebook Instagram et autres là tout
de suite
d'être en mesure de vendre de la
publicité parce qu'il y a une volumétrie
puis par la suite on a vu les évolutions
de Facebook Instagram et autres là tout
de suite
d'être en mesure de vendre de la
publicité parce qu'il y a une volumétrie
puis par la suite on a vu les évolutions
de Facebook Instagram et autres là tout
de suite d'être en mesure de vendre de
la publicité parce que il y a une
volumétrie ensuite on a vu les
évolutions de Facebook Instagram et
autres là tout de suite
d'être en mesure de vendre de la
publicité parce que il y a une
volumétrie par la suite on a vu les
évolutions de Facebook Instagram et
autres là tout de suite
d'être en mesure de d'autres d'arriver
sur le marché des plateformes ce qu'on
constate en tout cas c'est que jusqu'à
présent l'Europe est toujours absente de
ce débat c'est qu'il y a aucune
entreprise européenne qui fasse le poids
et puis toujours sur le stockage des
données
juste un mot quand même
d'une part
malgré tout TikTok a commencé à bouger
après avoir fait après avoir vu les
décisions des institutions européennes
non pardon avant avoir vu les décisions
des institutions européennes quand il y
a eu les tik tokyx il y a eu une
opération d'un match control le patron
Tik Tok a fait le tour de la Commission
à Bruxelles ça n'a pas extrêmement bien
marché puisque il a suffi qu'ils
viennent pour que la Commission et le
Parlement décide que on le sortait des
des outils des fonctionnaires il n'a pas
dû être ultra convaincant donc
maintenant on entend parler du projet
Clover et on voit que il pourrait y
avoir des stockages de données en Europe
mais c'est juste l'application du rgpd
en fait
c'est à dire que le patron de Tik Tok
c'est fait expliquer par la Commission
européenne tous ceux vis-à-vis de quoi
il était en violation c'est un petit
début mais c'est quand même quelque
chose ça ne suffira peut-être pas mais
ça veut tout de même dire je le pense
que si on a le courage d'aller au-delà
de l'adoption de règles mais qu'on se
concentre sur leur mise en œuvre on a
levier parce qu'on est 450 millions de
consommateurs parce que Tik Tok
aujourd'hui c'est on sait pas très bien
125 150 millions d'utilisateurs en
Europe c'est à dire autant qu'aux
États-Unis et donc par définition Tik
Tok doit prendre en compte ce qu'il va
lui être dit par l'Union européenne bon
courage au britanniques qui ont quitté
l'Union européenne
X-Men merci madame la Présidente merci
pour vos questions je vais essayer de
pas répéter ce qui vient d'être dit
juste sur le plan de Flage évidemment
le problème que ça pose c'est que c'est
les réseaux c'est la connaissance et
ensuite c'est la suspicion qui est
nécessairement née dans l'opinion
c'est-à-dire quand ces personnes étaient
en poste est-ce qu'il travaillait déjà
pour leur futur employeur c'est une
question légitime c'est pas du
complotisme là par contre c'est une
question légitime qui est éveillée par
ce type de bascule qui devient
extrêmement fréquent et qui
doit être combattu parce que là j'ai
l'impression que la leçon a été tirée
pour la Russie donc on a poussé les
anciens dignitaires qui se livraient à
ce genre de pratique avec les grandes
entreprises russes à démissionné des
bornes mais personne ne semble avoir
fait le lien avec la Chine et avec
d'autres régimes
la responsabilité des plateformes alors
je partage tout ça fait ce qui vient
d'être dit c'est un premier pas et tout
dépend de la manière dont l'application
on a une expérience en Europe d'avoir
des textes qui souvent sont
progressistes et qui ouvre des nouvelles
voies mais dont l'application laisse à
désirer et et il va falloir qu'on fasse
nous tous alors là à l'échelle nationale
et à l'échelle européenne attention à la
manière dont sont appliqués les textes
qui ont été votés
les
États les autorités indépendantes et la
Commission et donc le problème qui se
pose
là je vais venir parce que là en ce
moment même au Parlement européen moi je
suis en train de négocier sur le
bannissement des produits de l'esclavage
donc dire ça n'a rien à voir mais
l'enjeu et en fait le système c'est le
même c'est à dire que le texte va être
bon j'en suis sûr on va trouver un
compromis et ça va être un texte très
important qui va ouvrir un nouveau champ
la grande question c'est comment est-ce
qu'on fait pour que ce soit appliquer de
manière à peu près harmonieuse à
l'échelle de 27 États membres donc il
faut que la Commission ait une
responsabilité et donc nous
au Parlement on explique à la commission
il faut qu'elle arrête d'être timide et
qu'elle accepte d'avoir une
responsabilité plus forte que ce qui a
aujourd'hui écrit dans le texte le
problème c'est que vous regardez les
gens avec des cernes qui vous parlent et
qui vous explique qui sont 5
pour contrôler l'ensemble des ports du
continent européen et par ailleurs voir
si par les milles les deux personnes qui
parlent chinois et bien ils ont
peut-être 5 minutes de libre pour savoir
s'il y a pas du dumping quelque part
donc en fait il y a un vrai problème là
qui est qu'on passe des textes qui sont
extrêmement importants pour protéger
l'espace européen en général et que
l'Union européenne contrairement à la
propagande des nationalistes et sous
dotés
et qu'on a un vrai problème de faiblesse
du budget européen et de faiblesse des
instances de contrôle à l'échelle
européenne on parle là de compétences
qui sont en train de s'agrandir et ont
tout le monde demande de plus en plus de
choses à l'Union européenne et il est
évident que si on veut protéger l'espace
numérique on va pas le faire à l'échelle
de la France seule si on veut protéger
le marché des produits de l'esclavage ou
de la déforestation on va pas le faire à
l'échelle de la France seule mais on va
confier de plus en plus de tâches à une
administration qui est celle d'un
village et ça va être compliqué là je
vais vous le dire ça va être compliqué
de faire face aux armées de lobbyistes
ou de ou de d'avocats des grandes
plateformes comme ça va être compliqué
sur la question des produits qui
rentrent sur notre marché
la question de l'objectif et de la
nature de l'entreprise
comme toutes ces plateformes évidemment
ça a été dit le but c'est d'abord de
s'installer de de se répandre et ensuite
peut-être de valoriser
sa place dominante
la question qui se pose c'est que là on
est dans les dans le moment de
l'expansion et pas encore tout à fait de
la valorisation
et comme on est
est je reviens à mon point de départ
dans un système un écosystème
ou pour reprendre les termes d'un
éditorial de Riha Novosti
l'agence officielle russe l'argent n'est
pas tout à propos de Gaspa
il y a une vraie question quand même qui
se pose c'est à dire que
s'étendre ça veut dire collecter le plus
possible de donner ça veut dire occuper
un espace dominant
si on est dans le même temps au service
d'un régime politique dans les intérêts
et les principes sont fondamentalement
hostiles
au domaine dans lequel on s’étend ça
pose une question c'est à dire que
qu'est-ce qui va être à la fin considéré
comme la véritable valorisation des
efforts qui sont produits actuellement
est-ce que c'est vendre des pubs et donc
faire du fric pour être très basique ou
est-ce que c'est une autre forme de
valorisation des données qu'on collecte
c'est-à-dire une valorisation d'essence
plus politiques et dans ce cas-là ça
pose un danger plus grand pour la
sécurité de nos nations
[Musique]